the white house is no longer mincing its
words
on the coronavirus lockdowns on this the
245th day of 15 days to slow this spread
the white house specifically our
wonderful white house press secretary
kelly mcinanny who makes all of our
hearts go bitter patter kaylee mcinnani
came out and used
a perfect word to describe the ever
increasing covid lockdowns she called
them
orwellian i think a lot of the
guidelines you're seeing
are orwellian um let me start by saying
the cdc has put out considerations
as we prepare to go about thanksgiving
about socially distancing wearing masks
doing what you can
there's a whole list a page of very good
considerations and in that they say
we're not recommending a certain number
of people but we are giving
considerations that you should
put in place and i think that's the
american way the american people know
how to protect their health we've uh
dealt with kovid for many months but
it's orwellian
it is orwellian there's a whole lot of
newspeak going on
and there are a whole lot of thought
police on the left
the left wants to defund the police i
think probably it would be a little
wiser to defund
the thought police particularly as they
ramp
up their control i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from bart
simpson i imagine that's a pseudonym but
that's what he says his name is
bart simpson writes funeral homes should
add a republican
voting option for the deceased i think
that's absolutely true
you know conservatives have long said i
think this is chesterton's word
that because we view tradition so highly
because we look to our founding fathers
because we look to our
ancestors that we're the greatest
democrats of all
because we don't just want to
enfranchise the living people we
also want to enfranchise the people who
came before us we want to learn from
from their wisdom we want a democracy of
the dead
and the left obviously took that
suggestion and they really they got it
just a little bit wrong
because what they ended up doing is
putting ballots in the hands of dead
people
in states all over this country but i
agree if the dead are going to be
enfranchised if we're going to do a lot
of
dead voter outreach we need to uh we
need to make sure that the democrats
lose their lock
on that vote i also have some exciting
news for this show
before we get into the thought police
who are almost certainly going to come
in
and shut down all of the exciting news
that we have we are going to be adding a
fifth show to the michael knowles show
you know i've been getting off easy
i've been doing four shows per week
since the beginning of this show
i take that fifth day it's very
important that i wake up
early and start drinking and smoking
cigars and you didn't need that you know
you need a little
mental health day a little time to relax
and unwind well
that is no more we will be adding a
fifth show
starting very shortly and we are going
to be going
to radio a big announcement just came
out last night
you know i had such a great time filling
in for rush limbaugh
last friday it was such a thrill to do
it truly
a singular honor and then i find out
this week that westwood one is going to
be syndicating the michael knowles show
to terrestrial radio i'm thrilled with
this
obviously as big technology is coming in
and clamping down on conservatives and
very often this show in particular
i'm very glad that we can expand to new
markets and we can expand to new media
as well
all around the country so you can check
that out too that's going to be coming
january 4th very very exciting stuff
i'm really you know it's just a matter
of responsibility
to go out and make sure that we get our
message out
everywhere because people are coming
after you
all the time one other thing you can do
to be very responsible is
refinance your high interest credit card
balances you know you can be politically
responsible but you can be financially
responsible too
you can save with a credit card
consolation loan from lightstream rates
start at 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
the rate is fixed so it will never go up
over the cost of the loan
over the whole life of the loan rather
plus there are no fees lightstream
believes
that people with good credit deserve a
better loan experience and that's
exactly what they deliver
there's no bait and switch here it's
it's really helpful i've seen this in
friends and family members
they will let high interest credit cards
ruin their finances don't do it you can
save today my listeners actually
can save even more with an additional
interest rate discount
the only way to get this discount is to
go to lightstream.com
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s that is l-i-g-h-t
s-t-r-e-a-m slash
knowles subject credit approval rates
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include 0.50
autopay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit
terms and conditions apply offers are
subject to change without notice visit
lightstream.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s for more information
kaylee mcenany calls out the orwellian
guidelines i'm pleased she did this
i i felt the the trump administration
handled this virus
about as well as anybody could but it
still left a lot to be desired you know
this was
a sort of singular attack both as a
scientific and
viral matter from china and then as a
political matter from the left in the
united states
the way they exploited these lockdowns
for political purposes
and early on you heard president trump
you know using very cautious language
about it
now though the white house is saying
look these guidelines are orwellian
they're absolutely over the top this is
the thought police coming in
uh you know any any term that you could
imagine from george orwell's 1984.
you know the term orwellian is overused
sometimes people make fun of it
the reason it's overused is because many
if not most people read 1984 in school
well today i think people just read
ebram candy in school you know and white
fragility and all that stuff but
at least until very recently you read
1984 in school
and so uh people would use that term
and uh you know people would ask does
this really describe
our society or do people just use it
because it's one of the few books that
they actually
have read you know it's sort of like how
everyone compares every historical
moment to
the holocaust or the fall of the roman
empire because of those
the only two historical events anyone
knows anything about
however the the term orwellian
is apt here it's well used kaylee
mcinnini was right
1984 is a sort of political prophecy
right it was written
in 1948 and then published in 49 and
it's about this dystopian
future where an oppressive government is
you know using the manipulation of
language
to change people's minds and their
enforcing radical behavior
and promoting all sorts of all sorts of
radical ideas newspeak in particular
which is the language of 1984 is almost
exactly a parallel to political
correctness
but how did orwell do this i mean the
reason this describes society is because
it's a political prophecy and prophets
do not just
predict the future what prophets do is
speak the truth
what george orwell did here was not
predict
oh gosh how did he get it right he had a
crystal ball and he figured out what our
politics would look like
in 40 years or 50 years no
he just saw what was happening in 1948
and then he extrapolated that out we've
discussed a little bit
i mean just political correctness which
1984 prophecies very well
you can see the origins of political
correctness in the 1920s so maybe it
flourishes in the 80s and 90s
but if you were really paying attention
if you're a good observer you saw that
happening and that's what's happening
here specifically
the think poll that's a term from 1984
refers to the thought police you know
the the experts
who are constantly telling us what we
can think what we can't think
and who often preach one thing and
practice another thing you see this
right now in the democratic party top
politicians invoking the experts the
thought police
are telling you to avoid gatherings
they're telling you
not to have thanksgiving dinner they're
telling you if you do have thanksgiving
you can only invite 10 people so your
least favorite children are not allowed
to go to thanksgiving they have to sit
outside
maybe next year they'll be better girls
and boys and then they can get invited
to thanksgiving too they're telling you
to wear the masks even though
there's a huge new study just came out
on masks that
you know i hate to say i told you so but
uh i told you so
proves a lot of conservatives right
proves a lot of leftists wrong on that
and then those politicians violate all
of the rules right
right now maybe they've come home by now
but as of a few days ago
a number of california lawmakers were in
maui
they were there with a number of
lawmakers from other places texas
and washington state they were there
as part of the independent voter project
conference which has been going on for
more than a decade
took place at the fairmont chaolani on
maui's
southwest shore they they shrunk the
size of this conference this year
usually they book 120 rooms this year
was only 50.
50 people from three different states
lawmakers
liberals fly to this beautiful shore in
maui
and they gather together and they have
nice wine and they have nice food and
they just have a lovely vacation
you're not allowed to go see your dying
relatives you're not allowed to go to
church
but democratic lawmakers they're allowed
to go to maui
with one another because they're not
afraid of the virus they don't take this
seriously at all
i highly doubt that any of them are
wearing masks in fact if you look at
some of the pictures floating around
they're obviously not wearing masks
because they don't believe this stuff
they're not living their life in fear of
the virus
neither am i because i don't believe the
politicians
but but sadly a lot of people do believe
these politicians these sociopaths
and it's a huge violation of the public
trust to do that
it's not just a few silly politicians
because you might say well i don't know
those
those democrat lawmakers they just don't
know any better you know they should be
listening to the experts
i'm right to to cancel thanksgiving and
wear the mask everywhere
they're wrong but actually actually
even the top medical experts
are ignoring these coronavirus
guidelines
in a truly orwellian manner so
you saw yesterday we actually played it
on the show governor gavin newsom who's
nussolini he's trying to lock down the
whole state again
new cellini gets caught going to a very
fancy birthday party
which he said was outdoors but it
actually looks like it was indoors at
the french laundry
which is a michelin rated
extraordinarily expensive restaurants
like 350 or 400
a plate and he was there with a lot of
his friends and they were all shoulder
to shoulder and nobody was wearing masks
and everybody was swelling great wine
and no one was afraid of this virus that
they tell you
you have to live your life cowering in
fear of then he got caught he made an
apology
and he tried to you know move past it
and say okay
no big deal turns out it wasn't just
news in there
turns out some of california's top
medical authorities were there as well
so
here we had the california medical
association
ceo dustin corcoran
he was there the california medical
association lobbyist
janice norman we're both at this dinner
so you can't just say well the
politicians aren't listening to the
experts the experts themselves the
the top dogs at this medical association
they don't care about the virus they're
not worried of course they're not
worried
it has a very very very very low
mortality rate it always has but
especially now
if you look people are always talking
about how the cases are spiking
throughout the country and
it was such a slate of hand because the
media went from reporting on deaths and
hospitalizations to the cases
but look at the deaths if you see the
cases spiking up but if you look at the
deaths they're way
way way way down they're barely
registering on the graphs
good thing right we now have these
treatments we now have these vaccines we
now and we have actually for some time
had treatments for the virus
and yet these people tell you you've got
to live in fear well they do not
themselves
if that isn't orwellian i don't know
what is and by the way the last holdout
for them
are the masks and we talked a little
yesterday about why there's this divide
over the masks it seems conservatives
hate the masks liberals love the masks
and some squishy people say why do the
masks have to be political and the masks
have to be political because they're a
public matter
when you've got hundreds of millions of
people all masking themselves like
banditos in public that is a
political question because it affects
how our society works how it's governed
how you can go into shops how you can go
into
access government services how you can
go into restaurants if you go to church
or if you can't go to church
obviously that is political and i have
been saying from the very beginning
that these the efficacy of these masks
has been overstated i have regularly
cited
epidemiologists who have backed me up on
this even though i
take those studies with a grain of salt
i figure if the studies are are to be
invoked
then we should at least point out the
ones that support the conservative point
of view
pointed out that dr fauci said masks or
bs in the beginning of this
pointed out that the surgeon general
said the masks are bs in the beginning
of this
then through political correctness they
change their tune talk about orwellian
that which is not prohibited is
compulsory
now we have a study that even the new
york times had to report on out of
denmark that shows the masks are much
much much much
much less effective than we are told
that they
are imagine that imagine that what a
what a true
underdog story that uh it's just a
handful of conservatives against all the
experts and it turns out we were right
speaking of true underdog stories you
gotta check out this true underdog
podcast
raised in a trailer park with no clear
path to success
kicked out of high school multiple times
and faced with becoming a father in his
teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies
with his most recent venture power home
solar skyrocketing on a path to becoming
a billion dollar enterprise join us as
waller a four-time entrepreneur of the
year winner
shares motivational tips and inspiring
stories
and business building lessons from the
ground up he shares his life experiences
and those of his high-profile guests
to help others better themselves as
waller will tell you
there is no elevator to success the
climb only happens one step at a time
let every true underdog podcast be a
step that elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting or making excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
check out true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com
or anywhere you get your podcasts this
danish study
i love it you know i i don't usually
enjoy reading the new york times
about once a year i enjoy reading the
new york times and it's when stories
like this come out
they were wrong the alarmists were wrong
the masks do not protect the people
wearing the masks according to this
study
the danish researchers found out that
mask wearers were not protected
from becoming infected by the
coronavirus any more than their maskless
counterparts
this contradicts the mainstream
consensus
this contradicts the cdc which has
gotten so much of this wrong
and it reminds us that scientific
discoveries
are not made by consensus this is when i
want to bang my head against a wall
when i hear people at whether it's in
climate change or
the coronavirus or anything else say
well michael
the majority of scientific experts say
blah blah blah
okay so what is it true or is it not
true
science is not a democratic process
material inquiry free thought for that
matter forget just this narrow realm of
material scientific inquiry
all free thought als science in the
broader sense meaning knowledge
is not a democratic inquiry in fact the
truth is
very often unpopular actually
consensus is is usually a sign that
perhaps some thinking has gone a little
bit wrong
and that's what apparently happened here
these surgical masks
did not so we're talking about surgical
masks did not protect the wearers
against infection
with the coronavirus in a large
randomized clinical trial so if the
surgical masks aren't going to do it
probably your little hanky that you wear
or your dirty bandanna or whatever
you're wearing on your face
isn't going to do very much either now
there is still an open question
as to whether or not the masks will
protect the virus from spreading
and there's still an open question about
how exactly the virus spreads and we're
they're still open questions about
those much-discussed droplets okay
most people are wearing the mask to
protect themselves they might even say
that they're not wearing the mask for
that reason but that's obviously why
they are wearing the mask
they'll walk by you and they'll put out
pull up the mask actually i'll give you
the great example of how i know this is
true i don't wear the mask i almost
never wear the mask i've always thought
it's completely ridiculous
and i certainly am not going to wear the
mask if i'm walking around outside
and when i'm walking around outside and
i encounter some very
very scared looking liberal millennials
and you can always tell
whether it's the haircut or the maybe
there's like a
i don't know lots of kind of weird you
can just tell
you know they've got with the clothing
and you can see a mile away a liberal
millennial and i'm walking and they see
me without a mask their eyes bug out
like don knotts on on the andy griffith
show you know just pop right out of
their head
and they'll immediately even if they're
not wearing they'll pull that mask up
right over their nose
are they pulling that mask up right over
their nose because they're afraid of
infecting me
with the virus no i'm obviously not
concerned in any way
about being affected with the infected
with the virus not because i don't think
i can get it
just because i'm i actually think
there's a very good chance that i will
get it at some point
but because i'm not going to live my
life in absolute fear
and because i don't think the masks are
going to be particularly effective at
protecting me from the virus anyway so i
don't wear it and i'm by the way i'm
backed up by this dangerous study
they pull it up to protect themselves
and what we now know
if you're one for believe in studies is
that that is completely
ridiculous completely ridiculous but it
is orwellian
especially and people forget it now but
especially the way the masks went from
don't do it only idiots wear masks eric
swalwell remember the former future
president eric swalwell
said if you wear the masks stop buying
the masks people stop doing it it's dumb
don't do it
now we all we all have to wear the masks
that was a real orwellian flip
in the way that in 1984 the the country
oceania
will just switch which country they're
at war with one day they're at war with
east asia but they've always been a war
with east asia
one day they're at war with eurasia but
they've always been at war with eurasia
they constantly they send ideas down the
memory hole
they rewrite history that's what we're
seeing
but there's another feature of 1984 that
makes this moment
orwellian it's everyone's focusing on
the new speak and political correctness
and the rewriting of history and all
that yeah it's very important
the other aspect and i suppose it's a
minor part of the book
is that it's not 1984 is not just about
creating
a uniformity of pleasure it's not just
about creating
a kind of total conforming
love it's also about creating a
uniformity of hate
it's also there's a there is a practice
in the book called the two minutes hate
and every day everyone will gather
around the screens all over them
and the villain that contrived imaginary
villain will pop on screen and everyone
just has to hate him
and you just have to hate this guy so
much and then that's over and you can go
back to your work
we have two minutes hate here in america
we have two minutes hate and we we
actually just saw it in a viral
video that some some friends and some
listeners to the show have sent to me
asking what exactly white people
are superior at which we will get to in
one moment but as we discuss
this orwellian culture it's important to
remember that you've got to protect your
rights and institutions one great way to
do that
is to exercise your second amendment
rights and the
best way to do that is to have a great
holster the pending results of the
election
will doubtlessly cause a spike in gun
sales it's already happening if you want
to get a gun
i thought i'd move to tennessee and i
could just buy like a zillion guns very
difficult there are actually a lot of
shortages
if you are making a firearms purchase
because you're worried about the future
of the second amendment
i want you to be safe responsible and
carry with a we the people holster
starting at just 40 bucks 40 bucks for a
really high end holster it's unheard of
we the people holsters are custom
designed to fit your firearm perfectly
they're made right here in the usa
also unheard of these days because we
exported everything overseas
we the people holsters have thousands of
options to choose from
plus an amazing selection of printed
holsters their proprietary clip design
allows for you to easily adjust
both the can and ride of your holster so
that it will fit comfortably and
securely
at all times i especially love that
these
these holsters are made in america but
the thing i can't get over usually
things made in america cost a ton of
money
these are so inexpensive every holster
ship's free and comes with a lifetime
guarantee
plus right now you can get an additional
ten dollars off with the promo code
knoll so it was 40 bucks which is
already extremely low now you get it
down to 30. makes a great gift
and satisfaction is guaranteed if it's
not a perfect fit
send it back for a total refund we the
peopleholsters.com
knowles we the peopleholsters.com
knowles offer code
knowles what exactly
are white people good at that is a
question
being asked in a video that has gone
very viral on a huge youtube channel i
think it has something like
10 million subscribers to this channel
this
is the current embodiment of the
orwellian concept
of two minutes hate of dehumanizing
people
of suppressing one's own empathy trying
to stamp out one's own empathy
ironically in the name of equity and
justice and compassion
the video opens up with a simple
question what are white people superior
at they're asking people who i think
they're all black
but you know some i don't know race is
sometimes a blurry thing
so who knows but i guess at least the
premises that this
outlet is asking black people what are
white people superior at it starts out
funny enough what exactly are white
people superior at
well according to television everything
white man could fly
even a white woman she could be four
foot one she knew karate she could take
down 15 people
[Music]
what are white people superior at
man
[Music]
oh god what are white people superior at
they they just keep talking mostly about
their pets
white people love day dogs like that's
all you see cats
letting them get on your countertops
while you're cooking
yes i get that you love your pet but
like you need to take it everywhere like
everywhere
i guess you know hey emotional support
animals i guess
what exactly are white people superior
men like making cereal casseroles what
kind of casserole
tuna it's always tuna what do you mean
it's always
tuna using mayonnaise in a lot of their
recipes
making bland food unseasoned chicken
okay so
it starts out funny enough it's kind of
an interesting
aspect of the video that a number of
these people are
obviously part white i mean they're
obviously
some people would be indistinguishable
from white people but they identify
maybe they're a mixed race or something
like that
as many many people are but they
identify as black and they identify sort
of against
being white even even if they are in
part white but you know i think these
comments are actually pretty funny what
are white people good at i don't know
making cereal
yes it's true white people do prefer
cereal uh
you know what about people what are they
superior at all
making tuna casserole with lots of
mayonnaise yeah that's true guilty is
charged
i do i love a tuna melt call me i know
i'm a little swarthy to be a wasp but i
do okay that's kind of
that's kind of funny of course there's a
hypocrisy here because if another
channel went out and asked the question
what are black people
superior at and they gave any answers
similar to this about food or anything
else
you know the makers of that video would
be canceled they would be ostracized
they would probably be sent away from
the country and banished they would lose
their job it would be called racist and
white supremacists
sure there's that hypocrisy but i'm just
judging on the quality of the video
itself yeah it's kind of funny
white people do take their dogs too many
places it drives me absolutely insane
and it's almost always white people on
the little planes with the little yappy
things
it in the restaurants now all these
millennial white women pretend that
there are little poodles or little mini
poodles or
emotional support animals it is
ridiculous it's a funny thing we can
laugh at that okay
but then the video takes a turn because
then it stops being about these funny
cultural and racial
differences then it becomes
about resentment white people are great
at having fun that's a function of
white supremacy because they just don't
have as many stresses
as we do white people are very superior
at their privilege in utilizing it we do
not have the privilege
to do whatever and however we want to
what exactly are white people superior
at
uh not getting arrested yeah i was
driving down the street
with uh down the highway with a friend
of mine who was white when he was like i
need to i'm just going to pull over and
pee
and i'm in the passenger seat and i was
like please don't because the black man
thinks differently if i pull over to the
side of the road and pee
a cop is going to be right behind me to
punish me
what exactly are white people superior
insecurity pretending
fear being fearful of nothing being
ignorant
blame letting their egos control their
every move privilege truly killing
victimized playing the victim
congratulating themselves over that
they're incompetent at
or that should have already been done
they're superior at being
whoa that's some pretty bigoted stuff
right there isn't that these people are
pretty vicious
racial bigots aren't they this stops
being funny
all of a sudden these actually are
bigots i mean the things they're saying
are
are deeply bigoted and wrong and immoral
and the thing about it is just like with
all bigots it's not even
necessarily the case that they're wrong
about the other guy andrew clavin makes
this point a lot
the thing about bigots that we all get
wrong is it's not that they're
necessarily wrong about
what they're saying about the other guy
it's that they're wrong about themselves
they don't recognize
that they have the problems that they're
accusing these people that they despise
of having
one of the lines here is that white
people are really good at playing the
victim
the entire premise of this video is to
play the victim right so obviously if
you're going to
accuse the other guy that while you are
doing it yourself there is
some hypocrisy there and then one of the
lies of this video is they're pretending
that this is a racial distinction
primarily which and i guess it might be
in the case of they don't like white
people
but it's not a racial distinction in who
is making the video
they're trying to pretend that this
group of performers
are representative of black people
they're not
one of these guys was wearing an angela
davis t-shirt angela davis
is one of the most infamous communists
in the country another guy was wearing a
t-shirt that said dismantle
these are not a random sampling of black
americans these are
radical radical leftists some of the
most radical of all of them
right they were talking about cr people
with kind of crazy
political ideologies uh sort of
represented in sort of crazy outfits
because the one thing that the left is
trying to do
in particular is suppress this idea that
black people
are permitted to think for themselves
clarence thomas made this point during
the
the anita hill hearings in the early
1990s he when he described his
confirmation process as a high-tech
lynching for uppity blacks who in any
way dean to think for themselves
president trump has been saying since
2016 come on leave the left they haven't
done anything for you
and he made huge inroads among the black
population i don't think any of those
black americans were permitted to be in
this video
what the left is trying to do is
contrive and gin up racial resentment
to affect their political goals they
don't care about
black people at all or any other racial
group what they care about is that
angela davis picture what they care
about
is the ideology that she represents
radical leftism and then
they say they have the audacity to say
in this video
that uh what one thing white people are
very superior at is controlling the
narrative
what exactly are white people superior
making us believe that
we don't matter believing that they're
superior feeling superior thinking
they're superior thinking that they're
superior thinking that they are superior
self-delusion controlling the narrative
believing their own press
marketing of white superiority whether
you are republican whether you're
difficult whether you're conservative
like white people are really good
at upholding white supremacy how about
claiming that you know they are actually
a whole separate race
when actually white dna comes from the
black female
hold on a second i i'm not i'm not going
to make the biological
uh question i'm not going to take the
biological question seriously of whether
or not i came from a black female i mean
i did come from a sicilian female who is
darker than
probably most people in this country but
regardless of that point you've just
spent the whole video
castigating white people as a race we
talked about this yesterday
white racial consciousness is very very
low in this guy
pew research showed this white racial
consciousness is something like 15
every other race it's over 50 so yeah i
don't
i don't think about whiteness or being
white or anything like almost ever
but you can't make a whole video saying
white people are terrible white people
are oppressive white people do this why
people do that and also they think
they're a race
no i don't you think so you're the one
making that argument the left
is the one making that argument because
it's politically advantageous
but controlling the narrative every
institution in america has spent
millions of dollars practically
and has spent nine months uttering the
phrase black lives matter
you couldn't you could never make this
kind of a video
in the other direction but of course you
can in in
this direction and it gets it gets way
worse than that we'll skip around but it
ends on a point that the left is always
trying to make it's an orwellian point
for that matter
it it makes this whole racist
bigoted awful kind of argument the whole
video
and then they try to end on an
egalitarian
tone of equality just because our
skin color is different you're no better
than me you know smarter than me
no no superiority there
no superiority yeah okay no no one is
making the claim that white people
are superior and you know they are
that's a flat statement white people are
superior
but this video is making the claim that
white people are inferior
on the basis of their race that's not
egalitarian at all
there's nothing equal there's no reason
anyone should take that seriously
if this were in the other direction that
channel would be taken off of youtube
right now
perhaps it should be i don't know i
don't know i mean i'm i'm all for uh
for hearing out various points of view
the left certainly isn't though
imagine if that were in the other
direction you know there
we've seen a number of racial hate
hoaxes over the years they've cropped up
we just got another one
clifton yutzy 18 years old just claimed
his bmw was vandalized in a hate crime
that the suv was sprained spray painted
with racist
slurs including the n-word including the
kkk
messages against black lives matter and
the minute i saw this story i said that
didn't happen
it didn't happen i know it didn't happen
because that
that is not the sort of thing that
happens as a rule in america
that is the sort of thing that the left
believes happens as a rule in america
that's why it's so easy to point these
out and it's why the left always falls
for these and the conservatives do not
well turns out i was right this was
perpetrated by the alleged victim
himself mr yutzy
uh he also put a message of a pro-donald
trump message
on there put sugar in his own gas tank
that's too bad it was insurance fraud
and erie county uh and uh this is
obviously uh
i believe this was in erie county
pennsylvania somewhere over there
uh they are now going to charge this guy
for lots of crimes as they should
because this sort of thing really really
rips up america and it is just a crime
in itself
to commit insurance fraud normal and
decent people
of all races not these radicals
and these race hustlers like this guy
you'd see or like the people in that
video
but normal the majority normal decent
people
of all races reject this stuff you
actually just saw it in california
california
tried to reinstitute racial quotas
racial biases in hiring to disadvantage
i guess whites whites and asians and to
give advantage to black and hispanic
applicants for various jobs and that
proposition failed it failed 57 to 43
percent
and it failed not just because white
people voted against it
not even in particular because why
people voted against it because racial
minorities voted against it
latinos in particular who would have
benefited from the from the
the program that's a good sign and it
reminds me clarence thomas said this
very same thing he wrote it in
his memoir these kinds of
quotas these kind of programs this kind
of what what michael gerson called the
the soft biggest bigotry of low
expectations
these sorts of things do not just hurt
asians or white people or
even the country broadly they hurt the
people that they purport to help
because they damage their dignity
because they put them on an unequal
playing field
you know you hear this phrase no one's
equal until everybody's equal yeah well
okay sure if that's true it's certainly
true in this case as well
and i think you're seeing people of all
races waking up to that
that's a that's a very helpful thing
right before we get to the mail bag
important to note
uh just an election update i know
everyone thinks the election is over it
is actually not over there is a legal
process playing out joe biden is not the
president-elect
much as the media want to pretend that
he is we talked about yesterday how a
county in georgia just discovered
a pro-trump county it turns out their
votes weren't counted
and the votes went overwhelmingly for
trump so they finally discovered those
votes well a second county in georgia
has just found a memory card with
thousands of votes on it that had not
been uploaded into the system
used in the state and the majority of
those votes were for donald trump this
is fayette county
now the uh we were being told
that this was more easily discoverable
than the last
problem that was in floyd county well if
it was more easily discoverable why did
they discover it afterward
doesn't make a lot of sense how many
memory sticks have gone missing in this
country
one of the vulnerabilities of digital
voting
and there are many others as well one of
the vulnerabilities of widespread
mailings for that matter boxes of
ballots go missing
because they come in at different times
who knows where they're being stored
trump campaign's got a tough road ahead
they've got to
prove massive voter fraud they've
talked to rudy giuliani just on friday
and he said that they've got a strong
case they're going to have to make that
case the election is not over yet
the evidence of shenanigans continues to
mount we have got to get to the mailbag
but i have got first to tell you
why i'm so excited to start up this
whole new year and this whole new place
because there's going to be a whole new
me i'm about to get buff buddy
i am so i just got it a couple of days
ago my
total gym the premier model
the total gym fit gives a full body
workout in the comfort of my home
for about half the price of those
expensive fitness bikes the thing about
do you remember in the 90s you saw those
commercials with chuck norris christy
brinkley you remember those
chuck norris is still i believe the
spokesman i'm going to be the next chuck
norris okay
mark my words chuck knowlesis that's
going to be me you can do over 85
exercises on one machine
whether you're a beginner or advanced
they have everything you need to get in
the best shape of your life burn
calories and lose weight
what makes it so effective is it works
every muscle group using 12
levels of resistance you can work your
core you can work your arms you can work
your shoulders biceps thighs
your whole body in a complete workout
takes just 10 to 15
maybe you want to extend it to 20
minutes a day but that's good we can all
carve out that kind of time
now they have total gym tv with tons of
on-demand workouts it's great they've
been making equipment for 45 years they
have an a plus
better business bureau rating you know
that you can trust them head on over
total gym is offering
a 30-day in-home trial on the total gym
fit for just one dollar
one dollar what have you got to lose no
matter which total gym you try
my listeners will get an additional 20
off whatever discount they're currently
running
head to this is the best best deal
you're gonna get total gymdirect.com
knowles get the special offer you have
to go to this url totalgymdirect.com
knowles get an additional 20 off or you
can call them talk to an actual human
being 1-800-311-7166
1-800-311-7166 we'll be right back with
the mailbag
always running late on the mailbag but
i'm going to fly through these questions
and give you the answers that you desire
from isaac
dear michael my girlfriend voted for
trump in 2020 after voting for clinton
and obama in past elections wow that's
great
however recently we face some
disagreements over masculinity and
femininity
for example the harry styles candace
owens incident
she believes that traditional manly
activities such as chopping wood or
fishing
are shared by men who oppressed women i
explained that oppression itself is a
vague argument and that doing the manly
aforementioned activities
are also conducted by men who believe in
respecting and protecting women which
signaled a whole deluge of arguments
have you and sweet little elise have
faced any such arguments if so how did
you deal with them best regards
no we we really haven't i mean sweet
lilies and i have
have known each other since we were 10
years old so it's maybe at some point
something came up but no i can't really
think of it certainly not in our
marriage or romantic life together
because we just reject feminism
we just reject it if you reject feminism
your relationship your marriage will get
better throw it out
i know that we're not supposed to do
that we're supposed to pretend
that feminism is about respecting women
and we're supposed to pretend that oh no
maybe the new feminism is bad but the
old feminism is good and
yeah no some parts of feminism no just
get rid of it it's just it's a false
ideology it's a nefarious ideology
it's based on a false anthropology and
it makes everybody miserable
most especially women it's just bad get
rid of it
it's an ideology it's not about the
people we're told it's about sexual
equality it's not it's called feminism
it's not called humanism it's not called
humanitarianism it's called feminism
and it it it's a self-contradictory
ideology in many ways it's got many
different offshoots
and it's just wrong it posits most
importantly
that in the old and terrible days of the
past
women were victims and now we've got to
break off our shackles and liberate
ourselves and that way it shares
it's just an offshoot of marxism and
various other
modern ideologies and even before
marxism you know you know everyone
always blames marx for everything he was
a very bad guy with very bad ideas but
this goes even
even earlier than marx to the idea of
liberation a personal liberation
individual liberation
as the primary goal of politics
which by the way goes back all the way
to the garden of eden when we were told
ye shall be as gods when we were told to
disobey the moral order and you that
will make you free and it will make you
happy and guess what it didn't it made
us all
uh miserable and mortal and left us all
to die
the same thing is true today get rid of
get rid of feminism you'll have a much
better life men and women
are not constantly warring against one
another there will not be a war of the
sexes because of course everybody is
sleeping with the enemy
men and women are complementary they go
together well
women make me wake up in the morning i
wake up every morning i think oh my
gosh and not just be a sweet little
elisa has an omelette ready to go
because sweet little lace in particular
but then
women generally the sexual difference
generally
is a beautiful thing about the world and
we should enjoy that and
men have virtues word virtue right has
veer means man
and women have virtues and we should
enjoy those and not think that we're all
just out to get one another from travis
hello michael what did abigail adams
mean
well here's another feminist question
what did abigail adams mean when she
told john to remember the ladies
it's a very famous line in a letter she
wrote did he let her down
i have heard she simply wanted him to
remember he was representing women
but it seems to me she is asking him to
allow women to represent themselves what
is your take on all of this many things
i i think that the feminism of abigail
adams is a little bit
overstated uh but yes she she was asking
for more political representation for
women
the the whole i think i think we had
them pull
the whole letter yeah the whole letter
from abigail adams
says or the whole passage that's crucial
here
by the way in the new code of laws which
i suppose it will be necessary for you
to make i desire
you would remember the ladies and be
more generous and favorable to them
than your ancestors do not put such
unlimited power into the hands of the
husbands
remember all men would be tyrants if
they could if particular
care and attention is not paid to the
ladies we are determined to foment a
rebellion
and will not hold ourselves bound by any
laws in which we have no voice
or representation this is read that
abigail adams was
was demanding the vote uh probably
that's not the case which she was she
was demanding better legal protection
for women from their husbands
she was demanding better protection for
women for instance on property
uh she was demanding that women be
better represented in the government
sure but the idea that we would read her
as a 21st century feminist i think is
silly
she did have a little proto-feminism to
her there's no question about that
and it's it's also hard to tell how
hyperbolic she's being
if there's any irony or slight irony in
her language
we do know that john adams disregarded
that part of the letter but he did
consult his wife
he had great respect for his wife he
consulted her on a lot of political
matters
and so that is the case rather than this
ideological idea of just a uniformity of
progress
you know the science of progress the
science of history that the left is
always selling us on that
basically women were chattel slaves and
now they're finally free liberated
beings because
they're permitted to you know go on
tinder
and sleep with a bunch of men and become
middle managers at the widget company
because that that is like the peak of
human flourishing
uh that's that's obviously a very silly
argument to make
some errors are better for women some
errors are worse some cultures are
better for women some cultures are worse
some
some geographic regions are better for
women some
some are worse the thing to focus on is
not this kind of
silly view of history is always getting
better but to focus on
on virtue and and to focus on that that
personal care that one can have within a
relationship which was a very
very successful marriage like john adams
and abigail adams from steve dear
michael
a friend asked a question that i could
not answer he
would being entitled he said that being
entitled to the labor of health care
workers under government-run healthcare
would not be different than being
entitled to the labor of police and fire
personnel
how how would that be the case i believe
the government has a role in protecting
its citizens
and does not have a role in providing
free health care but how would i argue
the difference to someone who believes
health care should be a right
thank you for all that you do great
great question this is a really good
question
i think we've got to stop using such
liberal language we conservatives use
very liberal language and what i mean by
that is not that we necessarily
use progressive or leftist language all
the time
but we use liberal language as opposed
to conservative language in that
we're arguing in purely abstract terms
in these purely abstract ways without
talking about the real
institutions i think your friend
actually raises an important objection
why is it that having government-run
healthcare is socialism but having
government-run police and fire
departments is not socialism
well it's because those are different
products right those are different
things the
protection of one's life against
marauders the
protection of civil society and the rule
of law is one thing and it's different
than providing advanced medical care
which is always changing
but sure it may well be the case that
we pass a law in this country and say
you're entitled to health care now
what has changed is not the metaphysical
character of government
what has changed is not necessarily
tearing up the constitution
though it might have some constitutional
problems what has changed is then the
nature of health care right now people
get into health care they believe it's a
private field they have certain
expectations of how much money they can
make of how they can work the freedom
that they'll have
we the american people have an
expectation of a certain amount of
freedom in our medical care and then the
government's going to take it over and
change the product they will outlaw that
old product they will make a new product
which is government health care it will
turn health care workers into government
employees
that's a different thing and that has a
lot of problems i would stop
arguing about this at a purely abstract
metaphysical level and say i have the
right to this
you're violating my natural right to
to not pay this amount of tax for health
care but to pay this amount of tax for
police or something i think that gets
too muddy
i think it is overstated i think it
accepts too many libertarian premises
which are not defensible and are not
true
and are are counterproductive i think
what we have to do is argue from a
conservative point of view
which would be one of practical
questions
which would be one of prudence which
would be one of saying well this would
be better than
this thing would be better than this
thing the reason that we shouldn't have
socialist
medicine is because we have the greatest
health care system in the world everyone
who wants good health care comes here
we do it it's good for everybody it's
better for some people obviously
healthcare will always be better for
rich people i don't care how communist
your healthcare system is the rich will
get better medical care than the poor
i've been to cuba i've been by that
hospital i've talked to cuban people
you are being lied to if you believe
that
the cuban healthcare is equal for
everybody it certainly is not and it
isn't anywhere else in the world
we have a good system and we shouldn't
break it that's a prudential argument
we like to have medical choice and it
will we won't like not having medical
choice that's a prudential argument
that's an
argument of taste that's an argument of
culture that's an argument of tradition
the government is not good at running
these massive bureaucracies
corporations aren't that good at it
either but at least there's a little bit
of free choice can we reform either of
those sure
again that's not just a purely
principled metaphysical argument that's
a practical argument
that's where we should start making
those arguments i think those are more
convincing
i think those are more defensible i
don't think people want to privatize the
police except for a handful of you know
very
ideological libertarians i don't think
people want to necessarily
totally privatize the fire department
but certainly not the police
and i don't think people want to totally
make
a government-run healthcare system maybe
they want a little bit of a
government-run healthcare system we
actually already have that
in some ways but the way we're going to
win that argument is from defensible
premises that it will be made
practically appealing to people you know
this is something that
donald trump has shown us over the last
four years i hope he gets another four
to show us this
you don't need to have this perfect
ideological especially
libertarian purity that's that's
something trump broke that's why the
never trumpers became never trumpers
is because they were so furious that he
wouldn't espouse their same bumper
stickers and their same slogans
they were so furious that he would just
talk to people and he's talking to in a
practical way
and they said that's not true
conservatism yes it is
it's much more conservative than the
bumper sticker
dime store philosophizing that we've
been getting for 20 or 30 years
previously
from people who were only speaking the
abstract and were ignoring actual
americans who who actually on the right
were committing the same problems that
they accuse the left of committing
where the left will always say who cares
if it works in practice does it work in
theory
too many conservatives quoting what
we're doing that too and i think that we
if we learn any lessons from trump that
ought to be
one of them talk about prudence talk
about practice talk about
personal relationships getting back to
the earlier mailbag questions
talk about real things don't get so lost
in your own theories and ideology
that you become disconnected from the
rest of the world that you become to use
an
overused but apt word orwellian
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show see you on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there
you